hi guys I'm Callie I'm here with Jake
Decker we're at e3 2017 and we just got
to play a little bit of Far Cry 5 the
upcoming sequel to that long-running
series it's set in Montana which I think
we were both really interested in yeah I
think the setting overall was probably
my favorite thing that they showed off
there's something so cool about being
able to drive around Montana listening
to the Black Keys which was it like four
or five Black Keys songs on that radio
you can't like switch the radio station
it's just cool because farcry has always
been in like quote unquote exotic
locations and they're bringing it to
America which obviously uh we're
Americans so for us that's more of a
familiar setting so I think is really
interesting that they're kind of
tackling something that's a little bit
closer to home
um and I liked exploring that and seeing
things that look like my you know my
grandparents town like that I would go
to in the Midwest so I was really
interested in it although the gameplay
does feel just kind of like more farcry
yeah so well the setting is I think is
very interesting I think the gameplay is
not I don't say bland cuz it's still
it's still fun but it's it it's been
done they've done it yeah when with four
and three yeah um but that being said it
still seemed pretty solid yeah I mean
it's not you're definitely not bland
like I blew up a car and like killed
like yeah five cultists at once and you
know the AI snipe from a water tower and
I just all the stuff it was it was fun
to play but not particularly inventive
and also it's a little bit rough right
now from what we played obviously it's
not final but that was kind of like okay
I'm waiting to see more from that you
want a little bit more from the gameplay
uh I also got to do an aerial dogfight I
know if you did that
um but that felt a little not not
sluggish but like too floaty I really
really struggle to take the only other
plane and uh that was a little weird for
me like it didn't seem like fully
fleshed out yeah I wasn't a huge fan of
the flying either um I I had a bit of
trouble taking down that plane as well
but it was freeing to be able to get in
a plane because in the previous Far Cry
games you could get in like these tiny
little helicopters I think in for you
could and in this one you can actually
get in a plane and fly around and I
think the real appeal of that will just
be able to fly around
countryside of Montana in this plane
unfortunately the demo area that we were
in was actually pretty small he's good
to see a lot of it but I think still and
especially with a co-op buddy I think
that would be a lot of fun yeah it's
really pretty and also just doing a
bombing run was cool but yeah there was
one thing I really really liked there's
something called guns for hire that we
got to experiment with through the demo
I just kind of picked somebody who has a
different play style I picked the best
gun for hire which was a dog named
boomer named boomer and he can stealth
kill enemies for you and also you can
pet him and he licks your face so you
know that that was the best thing I did
use boomer but then I also tried the
sniper named Grace and she was pretty
cool it was kind of cool just wandering
around you'd see her green light and she
she was kind of like quiet from Metal
Gear Solid 5 but I'm too used to see how
this guns have higher thing will work
because if it's just you have one guy
helping you out for the like I hope
there's a little bit more to it yeah and
the dog like I love the dog he didn't
always successfully kill people for me I
ended up kind of finishing them off for
him and so I was I felt like he was not
quite up to par but it's still a good
boy yeah yeah I think where that game
will shine will definitely be co-op I'm
excited to be able to play that and
co-op overall though what did you think
of Far Cry 5 I had fun with it I don't
know how much of it I'll play when it
comes out because it does seem very
formulaic of a Far Cry game yet which is
I'm sure is great for some people and to
be honest like in co-op I'm gonna have a
lot of fun with that but I'm more
looking forward to Assassin's Creed I
think yeah I think with Far Cry 5 we
didn't get to see a lot of the story and
that's what's intriguing me most about
this game I think the setting is
interesting I liked getting to check
that out but we got basically no story
stuff out of this demo and that's really
where it sets itself apart from previous
Far Cry games um and some not seeing
that I just really don't know how I'll
feel about it um yeah but I'm I'm still
tentative I mean we didn't get to see
that much so I'll give it a chance yeah
it was a very very small area well for
more on Far Cry 5 be sure to follow our
III hub we'll have more news coming to
you and be sure to subscribe so you
don't miss any news coming out of III
2017
wait more this week
[Music]